hi i'm ria and today i'm going to show
you how to make three amazing recipes
using homemade bread dough
so this bread dough recipe i got it from
the restaurant i used to work for
our pastry chef jun who is my mentor he
told me this recipe it's very versatile
recipe so i made a three different way
of you can make something at home i used
to make this every day because we make
it fresh every day when you are using
yeast east likes room temperature water
and a day like sugar don't use hot water
because that kills yeast and cold water
doesn't activate the yeast so make sure
to use lukewarm water and you have to
knead it very well about eight to ten
minutes until dough becomes very bouncy
so this is kind of how i'm porking the
dough and it bounced back also you have
to reset and rise the dough about one
hour to two hours in a warmer place
[Music]
another trick when you are shaping
dinner roll is to close the seam so it
kind of holds nice cute round shape
[Music]
if you wanted to make it the day in
advance you can make the dough and put
it in the refrigerator and rest it for
overnight
[Music]
one of the bread recipe is sticky bun
the sticky bun was really good it was
very delicious
sticky pan is a bread with sweet caramel
on the bottom it's like gooey caramel
bread it's so good sticky pans is great
for breakfast and i love sweet breakfast
like french toast and pancakes and
waffles it's my favorite i feel like if
you eat sweet things in the morning you
feel less guilty so
i feel like you can eat as much as you
want
maybe
maybe not it's very different than
breakfast
in japan it's the same process as for
the dinner roll you just put brown sugar
and butter mixture on the bottom of the
skillet and bake it in the oven
[Music]
[Music]
so for focaccia
you use the same dough just instead of
cutting it into individual portions you
use whole dough and spread it then poke
holes with your fingers
it helps to soak the olive oil more
it's just like a nice feeling if you
kind of sink your fingers in the dog
so embrace that moment when you're
making it
i used rosemary olive oil salt and black
pepper i was called out by italian
audience saying that this is not
focaccia
but this is how we made it in a
restaurant in america so maybe it's
american focaccia
but it's definitely tasty
[Music]
making bread is very inexpensive and
easily impress your friends sometimes
making bread sounds a little bit
intimidating but this recipe is very
simple and easy so if your first time
baking bread give this a try
[Music]
yes yes okay okay
you